kpmg all state and goldman sachs big
layoffs kpmg laid off 1400 employees
its latest firm and professional
services industry is reduced headcount
because of coronavirus pandemic
allstate one of us largest insurers has
uh says plans to lay off 3 800 employees
the layoff represents about eight
percent of insurance approximately 46
000 employees so 46
3800 is going to be gone of the job cuts
about a thousand are tied to the
company's pandemic related fund to
policyholders all-state chief executive
thomas wilson said in an interview
goldman sachs bloomberg news which first
reported about the layoffs said the bank
was looking to cut
400 jobs roughly one percent of its work
for
citing people familiar with the matter
and in disney
28 000 people have been let go walt
disney has announced it will lay off 20
000 people at their theme parks
the layoff applied to domestic employees
of which about 67 percent of part-time
so
what do you think's going on there so
the the part i mean
no insensitivity but the part-time
workers don't move the economic needle
as much as
the high-end workers do it
the the problem that we're seeing we we
got fresh layoff data this morning from
challenger gray that they track
they track aggregate layoff
announcements throughout the country 2.1
million layoffs announced so far this
year
and that is higher than any year in u.s
history including 2001 was
was the prior high the problem that
they're seeing the problem that i'm
seeing is that
is that layoffs are going up the income
ladder the top two quintiles the top 40
percent of earners in america account
for 61
of spending can you say that one more
time the top two quintiles the top 40
percent
of earners in america who make the most
account for 61 percent of consumption
and our economy is consumption-driven
it's two-thirds consumption
if you if you want to think about it
differently they account for 42 of us
gdp
that's a lot of money so when you see
white-collar layoffs
there is a trickle-down effect but not
in a good way because the small
businesses that rely on them the dry
cleaners the restaurants
that they're the ones who start to
suffer if the biggest spenders
lose their jobs what's your solution
danielle you i mean you're an economist
what's what's going on here what's the
look there's more stimulus yes on more
stimulus but for god's sake get
something out of it i mean
so i mean look at least the chinese get
something for their money
i mean they've got high-speed rails you
know we've got potholes that would
swallow a small car
we can't even agree think of all the oil
field workers who are out of a job their
skills are transferable
they can repair the bridges they can
repair the tunnels you can put them to
work immediately
the corps of engineers has got trillions
and trillions of dollars of repairs to
do
do job skill training in germany they
did job skill training starting in
after the financial crisis they came in
and they said you know what
if if they can't work in the old
industry then we're going to retrain
them for the new industry their youth
unemployment is in the single digits
unlike the rest of europe which is a
cesspool
of very high youth unemployment give
people
a way to make a living people don't want
to have money thrown at them
but we need a return on the investment
for the money that
for the taxpayer money that's being
spent otherwise you're just going to
put another band-aid on it and business
travel's not coming back anytime soon
and yet we're going to bail the airlines
out
again dot dot dot and we're gonna throw
money at people to not work
that is not the way america was designed
to be
people that they have integrity in in in
their in their work ethic
so help them find a way to earn an
income for their families
period pay them to work not to stay home
yes
okay or train them if they don't have
the adequate skills fine whatever what
about infrastructure you alluded to that
industry no i mean
we we have we easily have four trillion
dollars of infrastructure spending that
that we
could tend to and think about it think
if you start repairing all the
infrastructure around the country
you're shortening somebody's commute
time in the future
you're making people's way of life a lot
easier in the future
and you're also making sure that other
countries like china that have built up
world-class infrastructure aren't going
to cook our goose one day